sehr geehrter herr obmann herr präsident
ist kunst kollegiums spittelberg sehr
geehrte damen und herren musiker sehr
geehrte damen und herren werte
konzertbesucher des diesjährigen
kammermusikabend ich bin general leuten
und eric reed college in der kommandant
der landesverteidigungsakademie und ich
heiße sie aus dem festsaal der
landesverteidigungsakademie ganz ganz
herzlich zum diesjährigen
kammermusikabend willkommen
wir haben ja voriges jahr hier an der
landesverteidigungsakademie der höchsten
forschungs und bildungseinrichtung des
österreichischen bundesheeres ein jahr
quasi jubiläum gefeiert
war es doch das zwölfte mal das dutzend
war voll das hier am abend der
kammermusikabend stattgefunden hat
traditionell ist der kammermusikabend
immer im frühjahr
er findet traditionell immer im frühjahr
statt
heuer ist alles ein bisschen anders
wir mussten den diesjährigen
kammermusikabend im frühjahr absagen
verschieben wir haben ihn auf den herbst
verschoben und zwischenzeitlich sind wir
erneut mit einer anwachsenden 21
infizierungen cupid 19 betroffen und mit
den herausforderungen mit beschränkungen
und mit einschränkungen die wir daher
über uns ergehen lassen müssen wir
wollten aber auch unter diesen prämissen
der kunst eine bühne bieten und daher
haben wir uns entschlossen den
kammermusikabend nicht abzusagen sondern
in dieser art und weise ablaufen zu
lassen dass sie geschätzte damen und
herren wir internet hier heute zu
gescheitert sind
wir wollten aber unseren musikern nicht
nur eine bühne bieten wo sie ihre
darbietungen ihre kunst genüsse nicht
nur über den virtuellen raum
heranbringen sondern dass sie unter den
gegebenen sicherheits beschränkungen
unter dem sicherheitsmaßnahmen auch eine
ganz kleine gruppe hier im saal
vorfinden daher sind einige bedienstete
der landesverteidigungsakademie hier im
festsaal zugegen um hier vor ort
beizuwohnen
geschätzte damen und herren ich möchte
hier und heute aber auch danke sagen
ich sage danke den damen und herren des
kunst kollegiums spittelberg dass diese
tradition aufrechterhalten wird
ich sage insbesondere und ganz
ausdrücklich danke schön den
musikerinnen den musikern den virtuosen
dem klaviertrio wie die sich bereit
erklärt haben erstens nicht nur diese
tradition weiter fortzusetzen sondern
zweitens auch unter den gegebenen
rahmenbedingungen hier heute auftreten
und uns kunstgenuss vom feinsten erneut
bieten
ich sage auch herzlich danke allen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern der
landesverteidigungsakademie für die
vorbereitungen und organisation der
abwicklung dieser heutige
kam des heutigen kammermusikabend und
ich sage ich ganz herzlich danke unserer
heeres bild und film stelle für die
erneute übernahme und direkt übertragung
in das internet und danke sage ich auch
ihnen allen geschätzte damen und herren
werte konzertbesucher die wir internet
heute via streaming hier zugegen sind
und dem heutigen abend beiwohnen
ich wünsche ihnen allen einen
konzertgenuss einen wunderschönen abend
dankeschön
[Applaus]
erst einmal herzlichen dank generell
wird die einleitung
sie haben sehr viel vorweg genommen
wir bedanken uns
entschuldigung das ist bisher war anders
sehr geehrte zur erinnerung zuhörer
wegen dieses vertrieblichen virus ist
das konzert in der sala terrena der
landesverteidigungsakademie nur via
internet aber dafür gemütlich zu hause
zu genießen
wir vermissen euch alle sehr unser
meister luigi speranza hat das
lesezeichen eintrittskarte mit einer
vergnüglichen grafik versehen
wir freuten uns schon in der
vorbereitung auf das jubiläum beethovens
beschreiben heutigen datum das uns auf
der zunge zergeht 20 center 2020 ich
möchte schon mal zitieren der den satz
formte die erinnerung ist das einzige
paradies aus dem wir nicht vertrieben
werden können
für fröhlichkeit sorgen das klaviertrio
in b-dur opus 11 gassenhauer betrugs und
das klaviertrio in h dur opus 8 johannes
brahms ich darf nun die ausführenden
vorstellen
frau yoko ono klavier und den wiener
philharmonikern benjamin uhr lesung
violine und violoncello der junge
beethoven lebte seit 1792 in wien war
anfänglich als virtuoser pianist edel im
vortrag sehr berühmt schon durch seine
spontanen improvisierten variationen der
gespielten stücke aber nur wenig später
auch als tondichter hoch geschätzt das
war bemerkenswert im musikalisch
verwöhnt in wien
wir schreiben das jahr 1798 beethoven
hat dem drängen seines freundes und
virtuosen klarinettisten josef bähr
nachgegeben neun variationen für ihn zu
komponieren
als vorlage soll er einen der zettel im
bagno aus der komischen oper l'amour
marina rossi als das damals überaus
beliebten opernkomponisten josef fleige
zu nehmen
dieses lied war damals so populär dass
man es an jeder ecke wiens von schneider
becker um nur einige zu nennen
hüpfend gepfiffen oder gesungen hörte
ein echtes schneider hüppe oder wie man
in deutschland sagte ein gassenhauer
beethoven konnte diese humorvolle
beschwingtheit in die komposition
einbringen
in jedem satz kombiniert er die
instrumente anders um sie am ende zu
vereinen wo alle gemeinsam das thema
spielen gewidmet hat der komponist
dieses trio seiner gönnerin bevor diese
komposition veröffentlicht wurde schrieb
beethoven diarra netten stimme für
violine um sicherheitshalber klaviertrio
gassenhauer erst das allegro con brio
zweiter dritter thema premium peña
allegretto es heißt übersetzt auf
deutsch bevor ich ans werk gehen
die variationen 1 bis 9 viel vergnügen
am zuhören
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wo
a
[Musik]
[Applaus]
red
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir kommen gleich zum zweiten teil des
konzertes johannes brahms trio nummer
eins in hd für violine violoncello und
klavier opus 8 revidierte fassung von
1889 drei monate nach der ersten
begegnung mit robert schumann
komponierte der 20-jährige im jahre 1854
die urfassung auf drängen seines mentors
robert schumann veröffentlichte er die
ersten zehn werke seines schaffens
darunter dieses als erstes kann man
musik werk im alter hat er sich am
meisten frühwerke überdrüssig davon
distanziert bei diesem werk hat er schon
bei früheren aufführungen umständliche
schwachstellen unnötige schwierigkeiten
gekürzt
1889 war es dann soweit also dieses
jugendwerk schonungslos und
selbstkritisch überarbeitete erwachsenen
stolz wurde gelungene revision die alle
seine vorzüge zur geltung brachte
verdichtung statt verbreitung
melancholie stadt sturm und trennt die
elemente eines gereiften tondichter
treffen auf die überschwänglichen
einfälle des jungen umgewandelt in eine
typische brahms thema trio opus 8 iv
erneuerte verfassung hat man damals
gesagt erst das allegro con brio zweiter
satz scherzo allegro molto allegro der
dritte satz adagio und der vierte satz
finale alle
[Musik]
[Applaus]
do
m
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
naja
hey
[Musik]
fr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
1000 tage die musiker dass sie uns so
etwas schönes gebracht haben ich bitte
nun herrn general die blumen zu
überreichen und ein paar worte zu
verabschieden
wir bedanken uns bei kurator am klavier
benny morris und violine
[Applaus]
er ist mittlerweile auch schon ein breit
der wiener geworden es in neuseeland
geboren ein weiter weg
und nicht zuletzt professor irgendwo
[Applaus]
vielen dank auch an die
landesverteidigung sagte mit uns dieses
konzert ermöglichte und danke allen
beteiligten für die großartige
unterstützung
es war einmal so etwas auch übers
internet weitergeben zu können
danke vielmals und vielleicht nächstes
jahr unter anderen umständen wieder ein
voller saal wenn wir brauchen das
publikum das ist inspiration
danke vielmals wieder an
[Applaus]